if a boy wants to wear a pink dress  encouraging him to do that is is great  right we ought to be encouraging kids to  be able to embrace the expressions that  they feel best fits with their  personality but the idea that that makes  him a girl is first of all untrue second  of all extremely dangerous to his  psychological development and third of  all grounded in regressive stereotypes  that say that girls are like supposed to  like pink dresses and boys are like  supposed to like blue pants right  feminists have been fighting against  these stereotypes forever and now this  ideology is to a great extent grounded  in the stereotypes that we wish could be  abolished